welcome to the show so we've quietly
sort of gone to war with Syria I don't
know if you've noticed a u.s. fa-18 shot
down a regime warplane after it dropped
bombs near us back Syrian democratic
forces fighting against Isis in the area
around tadka in Syria in the country's
north the US has also shot down another
pro Syrian regime drone in Syria this
week that's the third downing of
pro-regime aircraft so far in June and
there's a coalition actually that's
involved in fighting there it's led by
the US they've confirmed this latest
incident there's no doubt as to the
facts on the ground about it one
official said that the drone was shot
down because it was quote assessed to be
a threat and we're seeing a continued
escalation at a base near the Syrian
Jordanian border and as I mentioned this
is a coalition led by the u.s. not just
the u.s. involved there and then you
also have other countries there's a
number of angles that are going on here
there's an important Iran angle there's
an Australian Air Force contingent I
guess we would call it that's set to
restart bombing of Isis targets over
Syria we've heard now from Kentucky
Republican Senator Rand Paul who argued
against going to war without
congressional approval he says hey you
know we've actually been at war
illegally for a long time now we've also
heard from Democratic congressman Eric's
wall well who agrees saying quote it
looks like we are at war in Syria but
this would be a war that would be
without the authorization of Congress
and it's time that Congress votes on
what is the time line what is the troop
commitment and what is the terrain that
is covered so how is the current action
being legally justified many people
don't realize this President Obama
remember him and President Donald Trump
both justify this action in the exact
same way which is they point to the
authorization for the use of military
force against al-qaeda from 2001 16
years ago today and this comes down to a
pretty fundamental basic question by
striking pro-regime forces not aligned
with terror groups in Syria do you need
a separate AUMF authorization for
military force force or can you do it
under the 2001 you probably do need a
separate one and we don't have that Pat
I think you absolutely do in the 1973
War Powers Resolution it said that you
know the president can go to war without
congressional approval so long as
there's some immediate risk or there's a
national emergency going on right and of
course in the 2001 provision that was
specifically to fight against Al Qaeda
right al guy to maybe you know can you
consider Isis as an offshoot of them but
certainly not when it comes to the
Syrian government because they are a
sovereign state it's been a 16 year
process of sort of saying okay well
Group a is sort of al Qaeda Group B is
sort of related to Group A which is sort
of al Qaeda and by the time you get to
Group F for example or group M or q it's
much more difficult to justify using
that 2001 authorization of military
force and Virginia Democrat Senator Tim
McCain McCain and Arizona Republican
Senator Jeff Flake are attempting to get
Congress to actually vote on a specific
authorization for use of military force
against Isis al Qaeda and the Taliban as
reported by CNN last month and this is a
major issue that is being ignored and
again we I've said it a few times this
week Maslow's hierarchy of needs if you
don't know whether you'll have health
care in six months it's much more
difficult to get you to rally around the
the weather we have the right
authorization for military force in
Syria not that it's not an important
issue but that's understandable you know
in the u.s. attacked the Syrian Air Base
back in April that was huge news
especially because we didn't know if
tensions were going to escalate with
Syria yeah with Russia and it seems as
if that has calmed down but we're still
getting embroiled in this mess and I
would argue that the American public
does not want this well I would also
point to you know aside from the
constitutional legality and
international law angles this is setting
the u.s. and Iran on a potential
collision course and this is where I
believe Donald Trump is the greatest
risk lots of stuff
can be undone if Trump lasts until 2020
many of the executive orders that are
more symbolic in nature those can be
undone if Donald Trump even manages to
get in sort of on the path to approval
and activation some health care plan and
we'll talk about that later in the show
that can take a very long time and much
of it might still be able to be undone
if Donald Trump leaves office in 2020 or
shortly before who knows what the
scenario would be Donald Trump is so
erratic done on any particular day he
might end up bombing this country or
that leader or this other group he might
make an irreversible decision involving
military force and really do something
nuts and I don't know if it's in North
Korea the serious situation the
involvement of Iran
that's what's scariest about Trump right
I mean with a lot of these diplomatic or
domestic issues I think you know if he
has a four year presidency by the next
president if it is a Democrat those
things can be undone the example may be
getting back into the Paris climate deal
tour but I mean if you're messing with
the Middle East that could have
ramifications that last for decades